hello and welcome to video playing mt c
0 so get a classical news oh and with
micah three still cannot claim to know
that line particularly well but i have
refreshed some things recently that c5
okay yeah probably just taking right it
should be Oh Pepsi fired so that's a not
so common structure how to play with g3
maybe on and how to say yeah let's go g
3 III was also also possible
now that that whole setup I think to be
honest looks a little bit suspicious for
black at Bishop there i am that Bishop
looked like a bit of a problem peace um
but what to do now am I going with some
be4 here on hmm not sure why ok I'm
going going for it the seafoam part
looks looks weakish and ok now 95 was an
idea I'm not sure about it but it yeah i
think it's it's reasonable pace why why
is it reasonable and you get not
covering d5 here what am i doing ed cd95
ah what am i doing oh we my bluff worked
whatever a bluff is the wrong word I
mean I just blundered that oh my god he
believed me he just believed me ok
that's crazy
wow wow wow wow yippie yo yippie aim and
talk about being lucky okay wait if I go
night if for Queen g6 is actually rather
awkward yeah maybe bishop before I mean
it looks a little bit weird but
hmm I can take age 70 even though that
Kevin
what was thinking with the Spruce but
sometimes you really wonder what kind of
rationale you have when you chose them
when you choose a move it's really
strange sometimes um okay what you know
eh 5h for really coming and let's
reroute that
I'd like to treat it because i think
that the d6 pawn is some is a
substantial weakness at the end that's
substantial weakness is probably a bit
strong but it's something that I can
play against please God Bishop e6 them
mayo definitely and Bishop g5 if it's
not giving me anything at all mmm not
good let's do this first and then maybe
Bishop t5 if we trade see against the
porn i might have the more active pieces
as the bishop on a7 is looking a bit
weird okay now i can do this too to take
with the rook if he decides to take a
bow okay NC 5 195 not g5 is also good I
think yes attacking you six
your head looks pretty bad it cannot
cover a 6cm oopsie aight i will also
take you six black resign oh that's
early either position is very bad but
that's really an early resignation I
just I'm just completely just went
completely bonkers here with 95 this is
just not working at all he can take that
night I've sorry I for some reason
thought that this is covered I mean it
really isn't it just it just completely
just a one move piece blonder no I can
try something like this but it's really
not getting anywhere and as he has this
move there was some amazing I'm not sure
what I was thinking I was thinking takes
takes a pawn takes pawn takes and I get
the night bag where you can just take it
with the night and 95 is just completely
completely ridiculous but he somehow
believed me dan and now yeah I've got a
slide a strategic advantage him in this
position yeah the pawn structure is a
little bit more favorable for me there
were a couple of alternatives but i
think it was mostly reasonable b5 was
always interesting a move that i never
considered have it is it is strong right
it's really strong he cannot move the
night I didn't see many things in this
game yeah he can take and and play this
position it's better for why but it's
nothing nothing brilliant well this I
can also take b7 wow what a bad game I
should at least see the move okay I just
saw this and I saw c5 and 96 as possible
so and they can still do this this and
continue this position like rupee 85
this is not I mean it's an early
resignation maybe he recognized
recognized that he could have taken on
d5 which always makes the whole game
awkward if you if you certainly notice
that your opponent is a complete idiot
and has blundered apiece and you didn't
take it there it's always frustrating
maybe that happened in this game and
that led to his early resignation okay
very lucky one thanks for watching